are you doing let me start by saying
congrats on the movie thank you you did
a great job thank you before we get
started on this I want to jump back over
to for a quick second have you noticed a
lot more people coming around to
Jennifer's body in the last few years
yes yes there is a pretty profound
resurgence of the film which is
wonderful right so are you when did you
first notice it because I've definitely
seen people really coming around to it
uh yeah probably a couple years ago that
the couple an article came out or I'd be
asked to do a screening and I like and
it would be a full packed house and oh
yeah yeah somebody made a musical about
it in LA which is really crazy yeah
without a doubt
um so one of the things you've worked
with Phil and Matt the screenwriters a
number of times yes talk a little bit
about the genesis of this project with
them and creating this great character
for Nicole to play um I work now pretty
closely with them and when we agree that
we're sort of working on something
together which would destroyer was
always sort of the idea and so I get to
see the script or in this case an
outline pretty early as they've been
talking through the themes of the movie
and structural ideas of the movie which
was the case for this film and so they
had been talking for close to 10 years
about this movie and so once we sat down
was a pretty fast process of talking
about things I was interested by things
I would want to lean into a little
harder areas that they might want to had
wanted to amplify a bit and then they'd
go off and write they sent me the script
I loved it we went through another
couple passes with some input from me in
terms of how I saw it
directorial and so we work very very
closely at this point I would say it's a
rare thing that I'm just hearing about a
project from them kind of out of the
blue we we tend to be in deep
communication about a lot now I so I'm
guessing that then you have other things
that you were talking to them about now
that I just haven't heard about yes in
fact there are there are some great
projects that we're developing together
and one is more of a sort of small
studio movie there are a couple of big
bigger indie ideas that we're working
with and so it's just a question of
figuring out what comes next and where
we all collectively want to put our
hearts I completely understand Nicole is
tremendous in this movie I'm just
another voice in the wind I mean I
haven't heard anyone say anything other
than she's tremendous talk a little bit
about your reaction when you first
realized or creating the character
because she literally disappears you
can't tell it's her I know and it's a
really it's a it's a really rare and
profound thing to see an actor want to
go that deep and and disappear I mean
that is a really interesting thing I've
been I've been doing a lot of press with
her recently and and it's it's like I
keep looking next to her like oh right
that's Nicole because I never really got
to be with Nicole when I was making the
movie I was with Erin and it was a
really interesting experience to see how
deep she went and how she she was able
to sort of do that with me and alongside
me it was such a it was I have to say it
was one of the most magical creative
collaborations I've had with an actor
another thing that's really cool about
this you guys used no sound stages
you don't always on location yes which
is I know that can I be ahead and you're
making this on a limited budget yes so
it's like you just decided to say f it
I'm gonna make it as hard as I can
yeah yeah we pretty I funny because as
you were listing out those qualities I
was like wow it just sounds harder and
harder and yes it was as if we we
decided to make it as hard as possible a
process but that being said I think you
do gain a sense of what LA actually
looks like when you're really driving in
traffic and what kinds of neighborhoods
you really encounter and how big and
sprawling and diverse and sort of
crazy it really is and so that's what we
were hoping to communicate was this
collision of urban chaos with unexpected
beauty and sort of unexpected moments of
connection or surprise which i think is
this weird element of the city
I really enjoyed the the bank heist and
I know you had to do that in a very
limited way like two three takes yeah so
talk a little about the challenges of
filming this bank heist because it's all
in camera it's all in camera and and and
part of that for me was that I knew that
if we had to do it quickly it made more
sense to do it right in camera with with
real-world effects as opposed to digital
effects because actors actors actually
have to react to something they actually
have to hear something be loud they have
to feel like they're seeing something
eject from weapons and so that kind of
you know reality factor was part of how
I think I could achieve the the sequence
in in my limited means and it made
things a little bit more of a nail-biter
every single day but but I think it
ultimately lended a really kind of nice
authentic gritty feel to those sequences
talk a little bit about the friends and
family screenings you did any test
screenings you did and what you learned
from those that impacted the finished
film oh that's such a good question
I in my friends and family screenings
what I really came to terms with was the
fact that I had a little too much movie
I mean I had to my I hope I could say
too much good movie but there there were
much much longer cuts some you know what
I would say the first cut started closer
to three hours as opposed to two and it
was just because there was so much on
the page that that we did can I ask you
that's three hour cut was it more of an
assembly or was it more like oh this is
a cut of a movie that I like this is a
full-on three hour movie this it it
could have been a three hour movie there
was a way to have made that movie but
that movie
is a much more sprawling even more
sprawling exploration of the world of
the FBI the world of the cops around her
a little bit more of a sense of who she
was on her own as just a kind of damaged
lone wolf living on her own and what we
started to realize was that the balance
we needed to strike was between her real
world investigation the sense that were
really watching her hunt this guy down
for reasons we don't quite understand as
we're watching it along with a sense of
emotional attachment to her even when
she is a difficult and complicated
character and so finding that balance
meant shaving away and pulling away some
of the some of the scenes or sequences
that added great texture and great I
want to say expansion of the world but
but but distanced us a bit from her and
we needed to stay connected with her
while we also saw her on this
investigative journey yeah I have so
many follow-ups on the deleted scenes
cuz I'm so curious but I have such
little time I have to bring up something
else okay one of my favorite shows of
the last few years was halt and catch
fire oh great thank you I love hearing
that love that show great you were
obviously a part of that you know can
you talk a little bit about being part
of that show and what you loved about
working on it you know um Chris Cantwell
and Chris Rogers the creators are just
these the sort of new breed of a
Hollywood man in my opinion they are
smart kind decent feminist just
bizarrely cool people who also are super
young when I met them and I was just
like how is this possible oh my god
you're so great and they've remained so
great they've just gotten better over
the years and for me the idea that there
would be a show that put men and women
in the center
of this seismic cultural change in all
of our lives with first the birth of the
home computer and the personal computer
but then also the burgeoning power of
the Internet
I just thought man those guys are really
on to something and they were thinking
about things sort of two steps ahead of
me and so to feel like they saw what the
cultural shift was gonna be or be worth
exploring even before before I was able
to I just at their tender young age when
they started that show I just respect
respect them so much I loved working on
it cool thank you so much and again
Congrats on the movie thank you and I
totally want to see the deleted scenes
okay
yeah good to know
you